The holidays are fast approaching
and that means family gatherings
and parties with friends
and to celebrate, we caught up
with two audience members
who happen to be BFFs earlier today
to show them how to get a quick holiday do
that is sure to impress.
Take a look.
Hi, how are you?
How you are, Min?
It's so nice to see you.
Same, I can't wait to show you everything
that we're gonna be doing.
By the way, you guys are really good friends, right?
We are.
Like besties?
It's my work wife.
Yes.
So a good hair day is a very powerful thing.
It is.
And the confidence that comes with it is liberating,
as well as empowering.
It's literally the crown on our head.
I'm excited to see, Min what you're gonna do.
The Drew Barrymore Show has teamed up
with L'Oreal Professionnel
and I'm going to work on their hair
using the L'Oreal Professionnel SteamPod.
Do you think this is a tool that's less intimidating?
'cause some hair tools I think
if you're not a professional,
you sort of look at it
and you're like what do I do exactly with this?
Yes, it's user friendly
and I love how much versatility you get
with the different types of textures
and the types of waves
or even the way you smooth it.
Where do we begin?
Well, Lea, it's been ages
since she's had her hair smoothed out.
So what I'm gonna do is add a half-up style
with a French clip, which won't disturb it
but will also give her a different vibe
for the evening look
or if she's going to a party.
And for Jerika, I'm going to give her something
a little bit special
by adding different types of waves.
So it's a really casual look
that we're gonna make come to life.
So I think it's going to be really exciting
to show the transformation on these lovely ladies.
And also, to show them how to use it on themselves.
Well, I can't wait to learn too, by the way.
Teach me.
I'll see you guys at the end of the show.
I can't wait to see the end results.
Mystery begins, ladies.
(all chuckling)
So we wanna make sure
when we're passing the SteamPod through
that the arrows are pointing down.
This is because we're combining the power of steam
with the comb, which is going to smooth the hair.
Do you love how the hair is supple?
I am just in shock.
It's still got body and it's like super soft.
Looking good.
So I'll show you how I do the wave
that I have on my hair.
Go back and forth
and it creates like a S pattern.
And with your hair being layered,
I think it's a nice thing to mix up the different types
of waves that you have.
You can wrap it, unwind.
When you're creating fast and easy gorgeous styles,
this is my go-to.
And it can help you to create a lot of different looks
for the holidays.
I love that.
You'll be a new woman.
(audience cheering)
Okay, I'm so excited to see how their hair turned out
and Min is joining me here in the studio now.
Let's see a quick look before.
Okay, I can't wait to see what you did
for these transformations.
Thank you, Drew.
Wait 'til you see their hair.
Well, let's see it, Lia and Jerika, come on out.
(audience cheering)
I know.
Oh my God.
(Lia chuckling)
Oh my gosh.
Okay, first of all, Lia, your hair is six feet longer.
So much longer, yes.
Like literally.
It's crazy 'cause I didn't straighten it for two years
so I don't recognize myself.
(Lia chuckling)
How do you feel?
I love my natural curls but it's definitely fun to be able
to switch it up every once in a while so I like it, yeah.
Yeah, the combination of the steam
and the comb really helps to give you that control.
It's fast and easy,
and the shine is incredible.
Yeah, and healthy.
Jerika, how do you feel?
I love it.
My hair's naturally so straight,
so it feels awesome to have bouncy waves
and it feels like fun.
(Jerika chuckling)
Well, also, it frames your face really beautifully.
I see why professional people take an approach
where they're giving sort of this heart shape to our face.
And she taught me different ways
to do different curls.
So I can't wait to try that one
when I go get one.
So Min, what's a tip to keeping your hair looking
like this days after the party?
Can we hold onto this look?
You 100% can and I'd say the first thing
I'm gonna tell you ladies to do
is to get yourself a silk pillowcase.
So this way your hair, it doesn't stick or get ruffled up
on your regular pillowcases.
And then the second thing
is to get a dry shampoo.
So that will extend the life
and soak up any oil or anything
that might be happening at her scalp.
Good tip.
Thank you.
Well, Lia and Jerika,
we wanna send you both home
with the L'Oreal Professionnel SteamPods
so that you can rock these looks
at your upcoming parties
and these SteamPods are worth $250.
Oh wow, thank you.
I know.
And guess what.
Everyone in our audience is gonna get one too.
(audience cheering)
(indistinct chattering)
Thank you, Min, thank you, Lia, thank you, Jerika.
(lively music)